[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à strasbourg pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo émission spéciale break
site aujourd'hui le divorce à l'amiable
se profile cette image theresa may le
premier ministre britannique aux côtés
de jean claude juncker le président de
la commission européenne la commission
européenne et le royaume uni qui ont
fini par tomber d'accord sur les
modalités de leur divorce après des mois
de discussions tendues cela ouvre la
voie à des discussions commerciales pour
l'avenir post break site puis nous irons
à londres alors que le projet d'aéroport
de notre dame des landes fait polémique
en france à londres c'est l'extension de
l'aéroport londonien d'heathrow qui fait
polémique à les militants écologistes
continuent à lutter contre la
construction d'une troisième piste au
sein de l'aéroport londonien déjà le
plus actif en europe ont rejoint sur ce
plateau trois invités jude kirton
darling bonjour ça vous êtes députée
européenne britannique du groupe
socialiste et démocrate merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pascal durand
bonjour vous êtes député européen
écologiste à français à proche de
nicolas hulot merci d'être venus enfin
philippe juin bonjour vous êtes député
européen français du groupe du parti
populaire européen le monsieur europe
chez les républicains avant de débattre
voyons cet accord sur le break citadine
force annoncé il a été acté le royaume
uni et l'union européenne sont parvenus
à trouver à bruxelles un compromis sur
la première phase du break site on
regarde et on réagit juste après
[Musique]
le pas est décisif les mine satisfaite
six mois de négociations tendues et un
accord arraché en plein milieu de la
nuit vendredi 18 décembre theresa may
rivaux petit matin conférence de presse
avec jean claude juncker le président de
la commission européenne
sur la base du mandat qui m'a été donnée
par le conseil européen
la commission a décidé que des progrès
suffisants ont été effectués sur les
termes stricts du divorce
je me réjouis de la perspective de
passer à l'étape suivante pour parler du
commerce et de la sécurité et discuter
des relations futures positive et
ambitieuse qui seront dans l'intérêt de
tous l'accord à règle les trois
principales clauses de divorce d'abord
le montant de la facture les
britanniques ont dû accepter de payer 50
milliards d'euros à leurs partenaires
européens pour reprendre leur liberté
ensuite le statut des expatriés les
trois millions d'européens vivent
aujourd'hui au royaume unis conserveront
leur droits actuels de sécurité sociale
ou de retraites acquis outre-manche et
réciproquement
premier principe qu'une application
réciproque pour les citoyens de l'union
royaume uni ils sont près de trois
millions et demi
et pour les britanniques qui vivent dans
l'un des 27 pays de l'union ils sont
près d'un million et demi enfin le point
qui bloquaient depuis longtemps l'avenir
de la frontière entre l'irlande du nord
et l'irlande pas de détails pour
l'instant tout reste à négocier mais
theresa may le promet il n'y aura pas de
frontières dure entre l'irlande du nord
et la république d'irlande
en laisse à moins qu'une autre solution
ne soit trouvée le royaume uni a
formellement accepté que l'irlande du
nord maintiennent l'alignement complet
avec les règles du marché intérieur
l'union européenne et de l'union
douanière qui soutiennent la coopération
nord-sud l'économie insulaire dans son
ensemble un accord essentiel mais le
plus dur reste à venir négocier la
future relations entre le royaume uni et
l'union des 27 après le divorce en
matière de commerce d'environnement ou
de sécurité ce sont des milliers de
textes à détricoter et à réécrire avec
une date butoir
octobre 2018
[Musique]
voilà alors question toute simple à qui
ressort gagnant de cette première phase
de négociations jack layton a ling je
crois que le plus grand gagnant c'est
vraiment l'union européenne il ya peu de
compromis de la côte et européennes
accord final le gouvernement britannique
a dû accepter beaucoup des demandes
européennes et alors la grande-bretagne
et la mutilation comme disait pas mais
je crois pas mais c'est une question de
poids dans la négociation en a une qui
est fait entre 27 et deux coups on est
on un point qui est qui et pas assez
fort et la réalité c'est si on est très
dur ça va être beaucoup plus dur pour
nous que pour le reste le conseil que
l'on doit voir d'accord et donc donne la
négociation le poids dans les
négociations sont tout à fait dans la
faveur de l'union européenne c'est
impressionnant de mon prévu que on parle
de le royaume uni on est complètement
désuni occulté au côté britannique qu'on
voit au niveau politique et de coûter
union européenne c'est vraiment unifiée
ça c'est impressionnant comment l'union
européenne ah ouais c'était très très
uni fait dans cette négociation qui est
assez rare dans l'histoire
besson
pascal durand
je
vais rebondir la suisse et c'est la
bonne nouvelle du bric site parce que
vous le savez nous on s'est toujours
battu pour que le bric site n'existe pas
et que l'union européenne continue dans
une démarche d'union justement mais la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'effectivement le
départ des britanniques et le départ
brutal est un peu inattendu fait que
l'union européenne s'est ressoudé autour
de ses valeurs autour de ces principes
et que michel barnier à la capacité de
négocier c'est un très bon négociateur
qui fait vraiment un beau travail il
faut lui rendre hommage et en même temps
il le fait parce qu'il ya derrière une
unité après j'aime pas le terme de
capitulation parce que ça renvoie à des
logiques de guerre nous ne sommes
évidemment pas en guerre avec le royaume
uni avec les citoyennes et citoyens
britanniques il faut qu'on trouve une
solution on est dans une procédure de
divorce si on doit faire un
rapprochement avec la vie courante c'est
plus un divorce donc il faut arriver à
trouver des points d'équilibré bien sûr
comme dans toutes les discussions il ya
des rapports de force qui sont mis en
oeuvre et c'est vrai qu'à ce stade ce
que l'on voit d'abord c'est qu'on a
menti et quand je dis le haut monsieur
faradje et ses amis de youtube et de
tous ceux qui ont qui ont vanté la
capacité de sortir seraient bien
inspirés de venir un peu justifiée parce
que là on l'entend plus ils continuent à
venir il touche sa rémunération de
députés européens sans problème mais
pour le reste c'est zéro ils ont menti
aux britanniques ils ont fait croire
qu'il y avait un plan de sortie on
s'aperçoit que tout ça a été du vent et
qu'ils ont construit leur discours sur
du sable un peu comme nous en france les
eurosceptiques et ceux qui nous font
croire à des chimères voilà donc moi
c'est ça que je retiens il faut qu'on
trouve des solutions bien entendu parce
qu'il ya des millions de gens d'emploi
et 2 et 2 et de
citoyens qui attendent quelque chose tu
les joues bien c'est une défaite pour
les partisans d'un break si dur on
s'achemine vers un abri clip plus light
en fait mais je crois que d'abord il n'y
avait pas possibilité de briques c'est
dur monsieur johnson et tous les as
break sitter qui expliquait que du jour
au lendemain il allait sortir comme l'a
dit pascal durand racontait des
mensonges le arbres exceed ça
signifierait quoi ça signifie qu du jour
au lendemain la grande bretagne se
retrouve totalement isolé les avions le
jour où vous quittez la gaule à l'union
européenne sans ce en accord avec
l'union européenne les avions ne peuvent
plus décoller de londres c'est ça la
réalité
les règles sanitaires ne s'applique plus
on ne la grande bretagne ne peut plus
commercer avec le monde et donc le break
si dur qu'on a fait miroiter comme étant
un mirage de quelque chose
d'extraordinaire au britannique c'est la
plus grande catastrophe qui pourrait
arriver à la grande bretagne donc nous
aux républicains nous ne voulions pas du
président maintenant les britanniques en
ont voulu souverainement à nous de
défendre nos intérêts d'européens s'agit
pas de victoire de capitulation et c'est
simplement les européens grâce à michel
barnier qui a été vraiment excellent
dans cette affaire ont défendu leurs
intérêts j'ai un peu de mal à comprendre
ce que la cour entend dans son
paragraphe 49 est ce que cela veut dire
que quand l'absence de solution le
royaume uni restera dans le marché
intérieur c'est possible
mais sans qu est ce qu on dit en anglais
une c'est ça veut dire tu pas
tellement dans le débat s'était marié
que tu vises mais peuvent avoir la corde
les landes et du nord pour avoir un
accord final et est donc maintenant on
est on a eu aussi d'hommes 7 pour vous
demander vos commentaires on n'a pas
arrêté à entendre le mensonge de la côte
et des arbres existants pour l
paragraphe 14 9 ça veut dire qu'il y
aurait quelque chose spéciale nouveau
relation mais pour nous en lisons ce
texte flou lines avait dit qu'on serait
dans le marché unique les ja et à aucune
autre possibilité pour éviter mercredi à
10 heures en irlande le royaume uni les
landes où nancy l'élan du nom va pas
avoir un statut spécial de la veste et
le royaume uni ça veut dire que le
royaume uni reste
l'union de douane ailleurs et là le
marché intérieur c'est possible en fait
une des questions clés actuellement il
faut bien comprendre pour ceux qui nous
écoutent que ce qui vient d'être négocié
ce sont les termes du traité de divorce
et c'est pas fini parce que maintenant
il va falloir négocier les futures
relations donc on en n'est pas du tout à
cette étape michel barnier a négocié un
lapointe très dur c'est comment divorce
comment on se quitte ensuite on va
négocier comment on se retrouve comment
on se quitte un des points importants
vous l'avez rappelé dans votre reportage
c'est l'irlande le problème de l'irlande
par donc c'est une île imaginez prenons
un exemple des politiques vétérinaire
imaginait des règles de vaccination
différentes sur une île pour du bétail
qui ne serait pas la même au nord et au
sud de cette île c'est strictement
impossible c'est même dangereux pour la
santé publique donc il va falloir
inventer quelque chose d'intelligent de
règles communes à la partie de l'irlande
qui va rester dans le royaume uni est la
partie de l'irlande qui sera membre de
l'union européenne c'est ça que ça
signifie mais ça va pas être facile
en fait c'est une quadrature du cercle
face à hearts le cartésianisme
traditionnel des continentaux que nous
sommes c'est que en fait il y à un
accord entre l'irlande du nord et le
royaume uni qui vient dire les règles
qui s'appliquent au royaume uni doivent
s'appliquer en irlande du nord et ça les
unionistes ils sont très attachés font
un chantage theresa may puisque il
tienne sa majorité en réalité alors ça
c'est les règles et irlande du nord
royaume-uni après vous avez l'irlande du
sud l'air qui elle est dans l'union
européenne à la république d'irlande la
république d'irlande qui elle dit moi je
veux garder les lévesque tous les liens
que j'ai avec l'union européenne donc
jusque là on pourrait mettre la
frontière alors ça serait difficile
physiquement mais on pourrait sauf que
il ya un accord sur lequel personne ne
veut revenir qu'un accord entre les deux
irlande était un accord qui a mis fin à
des années et des années de guerre de
sang de violence et donc personne
évidemment ne veut ré ouvrir ce débat là
qui fait que en fait au sein des deux
irlande il ne peut pas y avoir de
frontières donc c'est pour ça que je dis
on est quand même dans un monde qui est
un peu bizarre je sais que parfois les
britanniques font preuve d'une
imagination extrêmement fortes pour
résoudre des questions insolubles mais
là moi je déjà vous que même si on m'a
expliqué qu'on allait inventer des
frontières 2.0 c'est très chic tout ça
c'était très bien je vois pas comment on
peut être à la fois dedans et dehors je
répète peut-être suis un peu trop
cartésien mais j'attends ce qui est ce
qui est sûr c'est que il peut on est si
je puis me permettre de theresa may
quelque chose d'assez stupéfiants c'est
qu'elle risque d'être soumis aux règles
du marché intérieur puis le filles on
reste dans le cadre guy actuelle elle va
être soumise ravec du marché intérieur
mais ils ne pourront plus prendre part à
la moindre décision concernant les
règles qui s'appliqueront donc là c'est
vers cela c'est vers cela qu'on entend
qu'on fasse mine ça risque c'est un peu
la situation de la norvège mais en pire
en pire donc pas bon alors là je laisse
aux britanniques la capacité à près de
2,2 d'expliquer oui mais c'est cette
situation que maintenant cette fugue
pour nous qui ont pas envie de quitter
leur parce qu'on voit que notre avenir
est beaucoup plus avantageux pour le
royaume uni et pour le citoyen corps
britanniques donnent lignes européennes
ont travaillons avec nos nos voisins
européenne nous on voit ça peut-être
comme l'homme le mieux de pied de
situation des sites reliés à la lune le
mois plus de moitié oui mais le problème
c'est que comme vous disais c'est on est
on doit accepter les règles on doit
payer
voilà donc la seule chose que l'examen
avait présenté ses deux bêtes le député
dans une palme européenne et le siège
dans le conseil et sa peau nue social
démocrate je ne sais pas démocratique
que tu leur fais dans cette malle
situation encore on aimerait bien mais
en même temps peut-être juste d'avoir
une pièce d'eau de le projet européenne
ce a laissé la place produire le projet
aux citoyens britanniques que ce mieux
devait céder dans le projet européen
mais et ça c'est une question de changer
la vie publique on voit méthane dans la
prochaine année mais ça c'est le choix
des britanniques maintenant vous allez
devoir choisir le mode de relation
voulait avec nous soit vous optez pour
un mode de relation vous êtes un pays
tiers comme un autre point final le pire
c'est que on n'est même pas deux de
règlement entre nous ce sont les règles
de l'om c'est l'organisation mondiale du
commerce qui s'appliqueront maintenant
ça je pense que vous n'en voulez pas
nous non plus ensuite vous avez une
deuxième possibilité c'est d'avoir avec
nous des accords privilégiés comme on a
pu en avoir avec le canada la corée et
cetera bon
soit vous décidez d'avoir des rapports
extrêmement étroit mais en étant dehors
ce sont les règles que nous avons par
exemple avec la norvège avec la suisse
d'une certaine manière fin avec des pays
qui sont proches mais vous avez raison
de le dire quoi qu'il en soit y compris
dans ces cas là vous aurez des
obligations et les obligations elles
seront d'autant plus importante et
contraignantes que vous aurez des
relations proches avec nous allez on
reste en grande bretagne direction
londres son aéroport s'agrandir des
milliers d'emplois locaux à la clé mais
aussi un des villages qui risque de
disparaître un reportage à londres de
françois goulard
[Musique]
à monza petite bourgade médiévale de la
banlieue de londres et s'appelle église
du 12e siècle sont menacés armelle
thomas installé ici depuis près de 50
ans en a fait son combat
entre l'aéroport et le centre du village
tout va être détruit et là au milieu ils
vont construire leur piste à
l'aéroport dispose s'agrandit la
nouvelle piste d'atterrissage prévue sur
trois kilomètres va couper le village en
deux et signer son arrêt de mort danny
faure sale et là de l'autre côté de la
piste vous aurez encore l'église et le
pub ils ne vont pas être détruits
mais si vous anéantis c'est le coeur du
village les bâtiments reste des
bâtiments et sans personne pour s'en
occuper il meurt
le projet approuvé par le gouvernement
britannique prévoit de raser plus de 750
maisons et celle d'armelle thomas est
sur la liste
même l'argent que l'aéroport propose
pour dédommager les expulser elle n'en
veut pas dessins ses efforts cette
maison n'est pas à vendre à aucun prix
personne ne peut acheter 46 ans de ma
vie et de mes souvenirs que j'ai avec
mon mari et qu'allez vous faire
tech moi là je mettrai fin mai jour
d'animaux à huile non je ne partirai pas
vivante de cette maison
une poignée d'habitants menacée
d'expulsion s'est organisé en
association
mais face à eux la machine bien huilée
dix shows s'activent
[Musique]
l'aéroport organise des dizaines de
réunions publiques comme ce soir à
feltham juste au sud de l'aéroport par
dieu
et cet ancien député a été recruté pour
faire le show
[Musique]
il y à plus de cent cinq mille personnes
qui nous soutiennent aujourd'hui et si
j'arrive à vous convaincre on pourrait
tous remplir le stade de wembley
il n'y aurait même pas assez de place
pour tout le monde ici on parle emploi
croissance développement économique le
discours est bien rodé
beaucoup de gens comprennent ce que veut
dire cet agrandissement
77 mille nouveaux emplois locaux 5000
contrats d'apprentissage pour les jeunes
de nouvelles compétences et opportunités
c'est ça qui est important nous
comprenons que les gens s'inquiètent
pour le bruit l'environnement et il faut
les rassurer d'ailleurs lorsqu'on a fini
d'expliquer le projet les gens
rejoignent notre camp
c'est le cas ce soir là après un buffet
bien garni des vidéos convaincante et
même si les arguments sont parfois
douteux les spectateurs semblent
convaincus
efoui si on n'a pas cet agrandissement
on risque de perdre beaucoup
d'entreprises dans cette région le zayed
business ne défilent pas si vous
regardez les autres pays tout le monde
progresse on ne peut pas rester à l'âge
de pierre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la sortie chacun reçoit les mails de
tous les députés et élus de la région et
on les invite à inonder leur messagerie
pour maintenir la pression
il faut dire que le sujet divise la
classe politique même dans l'opposition
travailliste de nombreux députés se
mobilisent pour l'agrandissement distro
notamment dans cette période post break
site
être connecté développer nos échanges
commerciaux avec le reste du monde
devient de plus en plus important après
le brésil
parfois des choix difficiles doivent
être faits et le peu de personne qui va
être incommodé on doit s'en occuper mais
c'est le bien commun qui prévaut
le bien commun à un prix 19 milliards
d'euros c'est le coût total du projet
qui devrait voir le jour en 2026
avant cela un vote doit avoir lieu au
parlement et les associations n'exclut
pas la voie judiciaire pour faire
abandonner ou ralentir le projet
voilà pour ce reportage de françois
goulard jus de 14h ling est ce que vous
êtes pour l'extension de l'aéroport
d'heathrow oui les choses parce que je
viens d'une région au nord de
l'angleterre qui en fait qui va
bénéficier de le fait qu'il ya plus de
connectivité et non du problème avec les
toits c'était une époque est très chargé
des gens et il n'y a pas ces places pour
les connexions à l'intérêt de la paix
londres royaume uni bon assez pourri la
vie et pour partager les richesses le
sud-est du pays vers le nom et vers les
régions dogues connu l'expansion des
défauts c'est vraiment important pour
les régions du nord du pays pour les
liaisons intérieures dans le nord du
pays c'est ça qui est
important
pascal durand je suis plus que d'accord
ça dépend à quel niveau suisse je ne
peux pas parler je ne suis pas compétent
je suis pas citoyen britannique je peux
pas dire sur un aéroport en particulier
par exemple on voit très bien qu'à
nantes un certain nombre de gens portent
l'extension de l'aéroport de nantes
atlantique plutôt que la construction
d'un nouvel aéroport
voilà je mets ya le principe le principe
c'est que on sait qu' il faut baisser le
nombre d'avions dans les airs tout
simplement parce que on arrive à une
situation de saturation climatique on a
donc la question des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre le train existe en grande
bretagne je ne peux pas me prononcer de
manière encore une fois je veux pas
décider pour les autres j'ai dit
simplement que 19 milliards c'est énorme
c'est un investissement extrêmement
lourd que peut-être une grande partie de
ces 19 milliards parce que créent des
emplois gens doutent pas une seconde
mais ces exemples on peut les criées
peut-être autrement sur d'autres types
de transport sur d'autres logiques sur
d'autres manières de travailler donc jeu
d'une manière générale il faut qu'on
repense la mobilité qu'on essaye de
réduire la part des avions et qu'on
essaye de développer les transports doux
voilà ça c'est le principe je le défends
après chaque dossier si j'arrivais comme
ça en disant bon faut arrêter cet
aéroport là ou là
je dis d'abord j'aurais honte de faire
ça j'ai simplement il ya des principes
on peut pas à la fois défendre l'accord
de paris dira c'est une priorité absolue
et puis en même temps dire il faut
étendre tous les aéroports sur la
planète surtout qu'on voit par exemple à
berlin ou madrid qui est d échec
terrible dans les extensions par
ailleurs sur le bondi sur ce qui était
dit tout à l'heure par mon collègue juin
on a un problème avec les licences
aériennes donc british airways serait
bien inspiré pour le moment d'être dans
une position de réserve parce que je ne
sais pas personne ne sait comment ça va
se passer ni après mars 2010 il buvait à
l'intérêt général les emplois la
croissance ça doit préval au pape que le
député travailliste dans le reportage
c'est évidemment fondamental les
transports le commerce ça crée des
emplois voilà et
l'idée de dire on va diminuer une
manière contrainte les transports en
particulier aériens c'est bon non c'est
pas bon en soi ces mêmes mauvais le vrai
sujet c'est comment on transporte en
polluant moins mais le transport il est
nécessaire et donc s'opposer de principe
à des extensions d'aéroport cetus est un
archaïsme et moi je suis assez admiratif
je vois comment les britanniques vous
dans ce débat ça va vite manifestement
quand on compare à faire notre dame des
landes ça fait maintenant trente ans
qu'on en parle on n'est pas capable de
prendre une décision alors j'attends
avec intérêt et je suis pas le seul
d'ailleurs la fameuse décision du
président de la république qui a dit
qu'il allait faire puis maintenant qu'il
sait pas s'il va faire donc il a créé
une commission c'est ce que disait
clemenceau quand on veut enterrer un
problème on crée une commission alors il
a créé une commission réchappa kg c'est
d'accord le terme enterrer un problème
est une effectivement belles images
allez on termine cette émission par
notre rubrique de fact checking c'est
checkpoint d'un combien coûte à l'europe
l'optimisation fiscale des gaffes à les
géants du web 5 milliards d'euros dixit
pierre moscovici vrai faux 1,7 chekpoint
préparé par audrey van brabant field
la taxation des entreprises numériques
gaffe à fin septembre le commissaire
européen à l'économie pierre moscovici
expliqué au quotidien le monde le manque
à gagner engendré par les gaffes c'est
une question de justice sociale et de
pragmatisme
nous estimons que le manque à gagner
pour les fiscs européen est supérieur à
5 milliards d'euros par an un chiffre
interpellant quand on sait que les
géants du web brasse des milliards
d'euros annuellement mais tout d'abord
que signifie gaffe à cet acronyme
regroupe quatre ans l'entreprise digital
google amazon facebook et apple les
géants du web accusé de pratiques et
l'optimisation fiscale grâce à des
montages financiers qui minimisent leurs
impôts concrètement les gaffes à profite
d'une faille dans la fiscalité
européenne pour transférer les bénéfices
qu'ils réalisent dans toute l'union
européenne dans un seul pays comme
l'irlande ou les taux d'imposition sont
très avantageux ces entreprises ne
dispose pas de présence physique dans
chaque pays où elle propose des services
ce qui rend donc difficile leur taxation
une situation qui énerve certains pays
membres de l'union européenne c'est le
cas par exemple de la france et de son
ministre de l'économie pour une lumière
celui ci a déposé un projet qui vise à
imposer le chiffre d'affaires européen
des gaffard plutôt que leurs bénéfices
comme c'est le cas actuellement quand
pierre moscovici parle de 5 milliards
est-ce suffisant entre 2013 et 2015
l'eurodéputé paul tang estima manque à
gagner de 5,4 milliards d'euros c'est ce
chiffre sur lequel se basent pierre
moscovici cependant il ne tient compte
que de facebook et de google de son côté
la fédération française des télécoms
rapporte qu'en 2011 google amazon
facebook et apple ont causé un manque à
gagner d'un demi milliard d'euros rien
qu'à la fin depuis les gaffes à nant
cessé de croître économiquement on peut
donc extrapolée sur l'ensemble des pays
de l'union européenne le manque à gagner
est actuellement largement supérieur
lorsque pierre moscovoci parle d'un
manque à gagner pour les fiscs européen
supérieur à 1,5 milliard d'euros par an
et bien c'est contestable
voulait réagir eu de katanda ligne oui
l'optimisation fiscale de gaffard mais
en fait c'est une de la raison pour un
nul le travail est dans le parlement
européen qui combattent pour restituer
doit aller une mpm parce que après
brigitte nous on n'a pas envie devenue
une parodie fiscale dans le maire de nos
à côté de l'europe qui est une de leurs
objectifs de cet idéal exit est donc
patent situe cette dabadie là comme si
cela des objectifs de 2 de ceux qui
voulaient le rexy de façon dur c'était
de devenir un paradis fiscal que la
grande bretagne devienne
apparaître deux choses premièrement ce
qu'il faut c'est que ces gens qui font
de gros bénéfices payent les impôts là
où ils ont des clients donc il faut
qu'ils payent des impôts en france en
allemagne en italie parce qu'ils ont des
clients en france en allemagne en tête
premier point et deuxième point cette
affaire c'est une réponse à tous ceux
qui vous racontent que la france pour ce
qui est de la france serait mieux si
elles étaient souveraines sortie de
l'union européenne et c'est parce que
cette question qui est très complexe
elle peut être réglée qu'à un niveau
européen et troisième point comme bruno
le maire dit je vais faire une loi
française pardon mais tout ça c'est du
théâtre il nous fait bien rigoler une
loi française tout seul sans lois
européennes ça ne marchera pas parce
qu'elle du rendement de la phrase
important c'est que là on touche à la
concurrence fiscale à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne donc certains pays se
comportent on a vu l'irlande mais en y
en ad'autres luxembourg évidemment le
royaume uni malte se comportent pays bas
et les pays bas ils se comportent comme
des concurrents à l'intérieur de l'union
est en réalité donc on a des chiffres
d'affaires qui sont faits dans des pays
où il ya beaucoup de citoyens et c'est
logique mais on va transférer ses
bénéfices ou prétendus bénéfices dans
des paradis fiscaux au sein même de
l'union européenne ce que je reproche à
peut-être pierre moscovici sur cette
question là il fait le job mais il ya un
point ce qu'elle il ne veut pas
dire la réalité c'est qu'il ya des
paradis fiscaux au sein même de l'union
et qu'il y à des aides d'état quand on
voit qu'on interdit par exemple à la
france juste titre sur les règles
européennes de dire vous n'avez pas le
droit d'aider votre sidérurgie et ses
terrasses et des aides d'état direct moi
je suis désolé quand on fait payer 0,5
ou 1 % d'impôt à des grandes entreprises
l'état ce prix c'est une ressource c'est
une aide d'état et c'est donc illégales
donc j'aimerais qu'on traîne donc on est
enlevé de la liste de la liste noire des
paradis fiscaux les pays de l'union
européenne
cherchez bien pour être crédible balayé
dont il faut balayer devant sa porte si
vous n'êtes pas crédible au sein de
l'union comment voulez vous allez donner
des leçons après à la terre entière donc
il faut que l'europe prenne en main son
propre destin et oui qu'on soit uni il
faut une harmonisation fiscale on leur a
pas complète mais c'est en cours c'est
dans les tuyaux et ça c'est très
important au moins dans le mode de
calcul d'exactement auquel cas une
assiette est là mais absolument merci en
tout cas à vous trois d'avoir accepté
notre invitation c'était passionnant
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis c'est
la fin d'europe et d'eau à rester avec
nous sur les chaînes parlementaires et
la rtbf bail
[Musique]